- Hello, Believe Nation.
I started the Mentor
Me series with the goal
to hang around people who've
done a lot more than us
and hopefully some of their mindsets,
way of thinking, values seep into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we've compiled a
list of all of the best clips
from Gary Vaynerchuk in 2016
of his best motivation
to help you get ready for an amazing 2017.
And as always, as Gary's talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(uplifting music)
- [Gary] It breaks my heart.
My friends, like, live for Friday night.
Like they know they get the,
like Monday morning is the worst.
It's just such a huge
percentage of one's life
I can't wrap my head
around what the internet,
this is not your grandpappy's life.
We have the internet.
You can build businesses or side hustles.
I just don't understand
why people relegate
into losing mentality and
just thinking they can't.
You can't because you want
to be on the bowling team
or softball, or play video games,
that's why you can't.
There's plenty of time, get shit done.
The level of complaining is unacceptable.
Look, what if I told you
this was the last Monday
morning of your life.
What if I told you you'd die this week.
Would you complain about your crap job?
Or that test you don't want to take?
I doubt it.
You would go much higher level thinking.
Well, that's really what it takes.
It takes understanding that if
you're not pumped right now,
if you're begrudging
what you're about to do,
if you're not looking forward,
please recognize the
world we're living in.
We're living in a world
where there's so much more opportunity.
This internet thing created
way more opportunity
for all of us.
Way more.
I mean look, you might not even be alive.
Like, your mom and dad could have had sex,
like three minutes later
and you wouldn't even exist.
And you're complaining.
You could've ended up being a bus, a tree.
I just don't get the mentality
of being head-down sad
on a Monday morning.
I'm going to make Monday morning my bitch.
I'm going to make you
Saturday, Monday morning.
That's what I want to do every morning
and that's what I want from you.
Please, take a step back
and think about how
awesome it actually is.
And then, recognize that
you can attack the world
in a totally different way
'cause you were lucky enough
to be born during this era.
If you're not great at it,
but you love it more than life,
should you go after it?
To me, the answer is yes.
The problem is, please also recognize
you're probably not going to get rich.
Like, if you love
basketball more than life,
it's just what you've always loved,
you might just make $49,000 a
year being a basketball coach
and having a lot of time on
your hand to play basketball.
It's just, you got to understand,
you can't have everything
all the time always.
It's just life.
I think happiness trumps everything.
Easy for me to say because
it really worked out for me
'cause happiness coincides
with financial upside.
I have friends who make $74,000 a year
that are just happier people than friends
that are making $18 million
a year that are not.
You got to do you.
But please don't let the
entrepreneurial society,
don't let me,
don't let your parents push
you into what success is.
It's different for all of us.
But, and this is the big but,
you got to be self aware about it.
Like this is back to self awareness.
I stay in my lane.
I'm a salesman, I'm a business builder,
I've done it my whole life.
I was an F student at 13-14.
My friends' parents told my
friends not to hang out with me
'cause I was a loser.
I'm more successful
than my entire graduating class combined.
Like, this is because the
market doesn't understand
that people don't get it.
You have to double down on your strengths
and you have to punt your weaknesses.
In America, there's
billions of dollars made
on selling you how to fix the things
that you're not good at.
It's a huge mistake.
You need to figure out who you are
and go all in.
That's what I did.
And so when you talk about
business or marketing,
when you talk about the New York Jets
and when you talk about wine,
I've got nothing but bravado.
Everything else, you should see me sitting
around dinner tables right
now talking about politics.
The level of humility and
the level of listening
you wouldn't expect from me
'cause that's not how
you're used to consuming me.
I'm loud and proud because
I only stay in my lane.
Pay very close attention.
I've got nine years of
content on the internet now,
maybe a little bit more.
I've stayed very, very, very narrow.
For me, it's lucky.
The reason I've been able to kind of grow
is my narrow thing is consuming behavior,
which I can deploy against anything.
So my narrow thing
happens to be quite wide,
which allows me to play, allows
me to be a good investor,
and allows me to run businesses
and allows me to be a person of (mumbles).
It allows me to do things.
- [Interviewer] And it goes
you barely really think
that failure propels you
Are there any instances in your past truly
where you couldn't get over it, and why?
- Nope.
(audience laughter)
- And that's why
- By the way,
By the way, that's the same answer
for everybody in this room.
That's what humans are good at.
We all fail.
We've all failed.
Like, my parents haven't
been killed, my child,
I mean there's people who
have their children die.
Like, could you imagine?
Like, the (beep) I deal, listen,
unfortunately, or fortunately,
it depends on how one wants to look at it,
I'm a pretty optimistic guy.
I lost three of my four
grandparents before I knew them.
Two before I was born
and one very early on.
So, it's easy for me to be happy.
I have my shit in the right order.
The health and well-being of my family.
And there's nothing even
remotely close to that.
Not even remotely.
People have gotten through much worse.
This is why I'm trying to
recall our grandparents
and our great-grandparents.
People were persecuted and killed.
I just, we do not have real headaches.
I don't know why I have
this highly emotional
and then completely
unemotional part of me,
but I mix them together
to create the balance
and that's what works for me,
so of course there's nothing
that I couldn't get up from,
like every other human ever
besides somebody who now
lives in some weird cave
that we don't know about.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] I do.
- We are strong as (beep).
We're really (beep) strong.
We're just being sold that we're not.
'Cause there's a lot of
money, a lot of money
in telling us that we're not
pretty enough, thin enough,
smart enough, good enough.
(beep) that.
I want to tell you that
you're the (beep) best.
Go do (beep).
We're going to make less money
this year at a hundred million
than we made last year at sixty-seven.
Net.
I don't mean percentage.
Meaning, they're in trouble.
Them.
(laughter)
I see it.
Which means I over-invested.
More people, more capabilities.
Because I'm going to take
the whole (beep) pie.
So, you know what I mean?
I'm not worried about how much cash
I'm going to take home in 2016
because I can take a lot more in 2020.
It's much more fun to take
home 44 million in 2020
than three million in
2017, 2018, and 2019.
Instead of four million in 2018.
People are, ninety-nine percent
of the market is short-term.
And the one percent that
isn't and has the talent
wins every time.
Which makes no sense because
unless you're going to die,
you should only play long term.
There was a stat that some
dude in Mexico City said,
one of these futurist type-of characters,
I'm sure he's smart, I have no idea who,
but he was right before
me as I was miked up
and he says "it's been
scientifically proven"
so I don't know if it has or not
because I've learned to take
that with a grain of salt
but that 85% of what
humans make decisions about
is irrational.
And that spoke to me.
Because, A, I think it's higher.
And, B, it's why I think
all my success is happening.
I am stunningly the most rational
and the most practical of all,
yet I don't seem it.
And when he said it, I was like, right.
That's why.
Because the rest of the
market is irrational.
Not on what I say.
I don't care if you want
to hustle 18 hours a day.
I really don't.
I really really don't.
I don't care if you want
to buy the New York Jets.
I don't care what you want or need.
You need to care about
what you want and need.
You can't worry about what I'm saying.
You can't worry about whoever
your flavor of the month is.
Maybe I'm your flavor
of the month right now.
Maybe, your consistent flavor of the life
is your mom's point of
view, is your older brother
who's guided you with good wisdom,
but wants you to be a lawyer,
but you don't want to be a lawyer.
You want to be a street artist.
You want to take the chance
of being an entrepreneur.
Or the reverse, or the reverse.
I, nobody preaches and loves
entrepreneurship more than me
but I think you see me all the time
talking about self-awareness.
Are you one.
This is the golden era
for entrepreneurship.
People ask me for selfies.
This will go away.
It may not go away for me,
but it's going to go away.
Entrepreneurship, like a rap
artist, like a baseball player,
like the heavyweight, nobody cares
who the heavyweight champion
of the world is right now.
Nobody cares who's an active astronaut.
But they surely did in 1969
and 1954 for the heavyweight champ.
They change, they change
and it will always change and
it will continuously change
and right now entrepreneurship
is in this pedestal
that's having its moment
and what I'm fearful of is
that you watch my videos and
you see my Instagram quotes
and what I want to
clarify for everybody is
that I hope you understand
I am not giving advice to everybody.
The only advice I'd like
to give to everybody
is to do you.
To find what your North star is,
to understand yourself,
to understand what your
work-life balance ambitions are,
how much, what your
financial ambitions are,
what your life challenges are,
the problems that you want
to try to solve and cure
as we all do as humans try to climb
those different mountains in our lives.
What makes you tick.
That is all that matters.
Don't do, I don't do DailyVee
or all these videos for you to be like me.
I don't think anybody should be like me.
Boy are there enormous amounts
of pressures and sacrifices
that I recognize are just
not healthy or valuable
to anybody else,
but it's also not
healthy or valuable to me
to do some of the things
that you want me to do.
Like, it's not fun for me to work 9-5.
Like, I will break.
I will be equally
devastated as you would be
to work til midnight every day
and so we just need a call to action
for everybody to recognize
we have to stop judging everybody else.
I'm not judging you.
I'm creating content for
you to use as a barometer
to try to figure out what you
like and what you don't like
and I'm trying to provide
value to my words,
my actions, and my
content to bring to people
to amplify their worlds.
And that's really it.
That's the clarification.
I don't want people to be like me.
I don't want people to do me.
I want people to do themselves.
And they just have to start
with understanding themselves
and not trying to be
like me in this moment
or that person the next moment
or that person the next moment,
but people that most win
are intuitive themselves
and figure themselves out.
There's a reason
that guys and gals like me
continue to have audiences
because people want to be
motivated to go and do things
or they want to learn
tactics to go and do things.
Whether I'm giving you tactical advice,
like filters on Snapchat or Facebook ads
or Instagram story collaborations,
or I'm motivating you through my words
because I communicate that way
or through my actions,
seeing this wake up at five!
If everybody who's watching this
actually did something about it
and then went on the course
of their version of it
then they wouldn't be watching this
and I genuinely know at
the bottom of my heart,
out of all the people that
want to build audiences
that I'm the complete opposite
of almost all of them.
Because 99% of people that
produce content like this
that are out there like I am,
the business of being
that is what they are.
I have businesses.
I have Wine Library and VaynerMedia.
I don't need your 14 bucks for my book
or to be in my course or this and that.
So I don't need to monetize you.
So I then genuinely want
you to never watch me again.
The problem is every time
you guys are posting,
do you know how many times
I see on my Instagram,
"Oh I needed this today."
And do you know how many
times I see that person
nine months later still hanging around?
If you needed it, then take
it and do something about it.
The reason there's going to be
a billion motivational views
today on YouTube is that
people love the feeling
of being motivated.
They don't like putting in the work
to do something about the feeling.
I think the biggest obstacle
to success is a lack of optimism.
I think the world, like, lacks optimism.
I think, everyone's like
your energy, your energy.
I've come to realize it's just optimism.
I'm just happy.
Just positive.
It's what it is.
Just, like, whatever
chemicals are in my body
they just allow me to see the bright side
and I just don't think I've realized
how few people have that.
Very few people have it as
black and white, hundred-zero,
Like, I just think everything's good.
It doesn't come naturally
to a lot of people.
I think that's like, you know,
if I was ever to say I'm
lucky about something,
forget about the business results,
it's lucky that optimism
comes naturally to me.
Like, I'm just optimistic.
I just think that so much works for me
because I refuse to accept the negative.
I don't think,
I hate it when people say it's an option,
or it's a choice.
I agree with you, Susan.
I don't think it comes
natural to everybody.
I think we're just starting
on the early stages of really
looking at mental health,
the brain, meditation.
What I want to do with my attention is
allow the 2,000 of you
to the tens of thousands
of you to take it.
I want to hand you my optimism.
My happiness.
My view of the world.
My opportunities that I
see in the white space.
And I want to give it to you for free
and then I want you to win.
How do you stay driven?
Well I'm going to ask you a question.
How don't you stay driven?
Well, let me get this right.
You won the lotto of the universe.
Which is, you are a human being on Earth.
You, I'm just going to say this,
I don't think people think about this,
you won the lotto.
You, in the universe,
you're not some weird specimen
in Mars that does nothing.
You're not a bird.
You're not a sunflower.
Like, you are a human being on Earth.
You won the ultimate, ultimate lottery
and you're not driven?
And you're not fired up?
And you're not going for it?
And you're willing to sit like a lump
and just wait til you die?
You suck.
Like, I don't know, you suck.
Like, how do I stay driven?
Because I couldn't even
comprehend the alternative.
The biggest poison in us is regret.
It's poison.
And I push so hard, so hard
and will through my vehicle,
which isn't meditation,
which isn't health and wellness,
which isn't nonprofit.
My vehicle is business.
I can't help it.
It's what I love.
I love building businesses.
I love competing with
you, I want to beat you.
I love that game.
But through that vehicle I will
always push a lack of regret
and awareness to how good it really is.
You're more than welcome to
tell me about how bad it is
or why you can't because, or what.
But it's just not true.
Because if anybody ever
did it, then you can, too.
Stop making excuses.
Stop complaining.
Nobody's listening.
They maybe pretend they're listening.
The market doesn't care.
What you need to do is
make one person happy.
You.
Then you can make everybody else happy.
You know why I like making people happy?
'Cause I'm already happy.
And so I implore you to
take this last little rant
and really look at your face
and understand, are you doing the things
that are putting you in
a position to succeed?
Not just in a business world, but in life.
Because it's super important.
Because boy, when you're happy in life,
you're (beep) business can roll.
And so, I'm just trying to figure it out
and I've been trying to
figure it out in front of you
for the last seven, eight years.
Trying to figure out the unlocks,
EQ, IQ, self-awareness, hustle,
I don't know what they are.
You know why?
'Cause like I told my dad,
it's 330 different unlocks.
And so I'll go to all of them.
They're all tried and true
and one might hit you,
yeah it was hard work
because I'm actually lazy.
I talk a good game but I'm full of (beep).
Or, it might be something else.
But (beep), one.
And so,
You're in for this, right?
It's good right, this is some good shit?
You're going to remember this?
- [Woman Sitting] I do.
- Good.
One (beep) life.
One life, my friends.
One time.
And honestly, I'll leave you with this
because a lot of you need it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
Are you inspired?
Are you motivated?
What was your favorite message
and what did you learn most
that you're going to apply
immediately to your life
or your business after
watching this video?
Leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to César Bonilla.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word
and posting that awesome
picture on Twitter.
I really really really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you to continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
much love, I'll see you soon.